the road to hell is paved with good
intentions and the mayor and his cronies
are trying to force these ordinances of
law-abiding citizens we say no to them
and we say no to any other local
government that tries to do the same god
bless you
god bless america god bless our Second
Amendment rights
[Applause]
[Music]
the reason for the second amendment
isn't so much for us to protect our
families it's to protect us from people
like you
that's the reason for a second yes we
uses the particular symbols of our loved
ones and probably work who are you to
tell me what mazes I mean detect date to
protect me my family in my loved ones I
want to support everybody here I want to
make sure that their rights we're also
being uploaded I want to let miss Mayer
Potato Head I've heard so many people
got in their potato pies so funny know
that no one here is going to comply with
his ridiculous gun laws not one single
person today is going to give up any of
their firearms
you